E aí
[Música]
eu já tive vários nomes agora me chamam
de ideologia
eu sou proibido de entrar nas escolas à
noite ou de dia
eu fui Algemado acorrentado
condenado culpado só por existir
e enquanto isso no meu quarto e o
enganado tem espelho a referência
e por isso eu sou quem sou eu já cansei
de ter que dar explicação eu sou quem
sou' Independente da sua compreensão
Brasil país que mais mata pessoas
estranhas no mundo
já são mais de 200 mortes em um ano
a fechar as portas nos virar as costas
não é para ser cogitação
aceitar e respeitar as diferenças
é o primeiro passo
a revolução
o Olá pessoal sou Julian
músico arquivista poeta e homem transa
a 3 masculinidade ela é plural
existem inúmeras formas de existir mas
hoje aqui eu vou contar um pouquinho da
minha
e quando eu nasci
e o médico falou para os meus pais que
eu era menina
ele só esqueceu de perguntar isso para
mim antes
nascem consegue subir o lógico
considerados feminino mas desde que eu
me entendo por gente eu me sinto um
menino
isso não era uma sensação momentânea um
sentimento que dava e passava era quem
eu era E cada vez que eu ia crescendo e
entendendo que o meu corpo na verdade
ele era um grande empecilho para eu
conseguir me expressar da forma que eu
gostaria
e a escola
foi terrível para mim era tortura as
crianças quando elas veem alguém
diferente Elas têm me ajudar a violentar
e a torturar
bom e foi assim para mim
e eu comecei a achar aqui Deus tem me
feito no corpo errado porque eu sabia
quem eu era dentro mas a sociedade
enxergava de outra forma então alguma
coisa de errado eu tenho ali e eu
comecei a comprar o meu corpo por isso e
foi achando que eu tava no corpo errado
que Deus tinha errado comigo De tanto eu
fazer as minhas várias orações todas as
noites sem ser ouvido
ouve minha mãe dizer que remédio é
demais era veneno e Aos sete anos eu
tomei todos os comprimidos da minha casa
a minha intenção era voltar para de onde
eu tinha vindo e voltar então com meu
corpo certo
E como você pode ver eu não morri
mas eu me sentia morto eu me sentia
morto todos os dias da minha vida até
aqui na adolescência eu pesquisei no
computador primeira vez que eu tive
acesso menino preso no corpo de menina e
bom graças a Deus para minha sorte tinha
resultado e foi aí que eu aprendi o que
era a transexualidade na época Inclusive
a maioria dos artigos ou matérias ou
documentários ainda era em inglês
eu pesquisei por anos aos 18 anos eu
tive a oportunidade de começar a fazer
uma companhamento com endocrinologista e
fazer a terapia hormonal e mudar o meu
cu é só que eu senti que não era ainda a
chance aquele momento porque eu ainda
tinha muito medo era um corpo que ia ser
modificado eu não tinha outra chance e
Sudeste errado as cirurgias na grande
maioria das vezes
eu não tinha os resultados que era
esperado então eu fiquei com medo minha
família não me apoiava a minha namorada
não me apoiava a sociedade não me
apoiava
então eu tentei pela primeira vez viver
como mulher
e como exigiam de mim a partir do corpo
que eu tinha e eu tentei de verdade
tentei por anos até que aos 23 eu tava
aqui tentando a minha segunda tentativa
de tirar a minha vida dessa vez não ia
tomar mais comprimido porque eu sabia
que poderia não dar certo eu tinha um
dinheiro guardado e eu decidi comprar
uma arma e tirar a minha vida
E aí que eu comecei a pensar em mim ao
invés de pensar no outro
e eu pensei que isso é a minha mãe e meu
pai se meus amigos a minha namorada se
as pessoas me amassem elas iam me
preferir vivo ao invés de morto e homem
preferi feliz mas vai de depressivo
bom então tomei a decisão de finalmente
nascer
hoje aos 23 anos apenas mas essa foi a
melhor escolha que eu tive até hoje
porque eu passei a ser eu passei a me
reconhecer no espelho e só por isso já
me deu vontade de viver
mas eu achava que tu ia se transformar e
eu ia virar o príncipe encantado e que
meus problemas iriam acabar ele seja
feliz para sempre mas não foi isso que
aconteceu
e na verdade quando eu comecei esse
processo de organização que eu comecei a
mudar o meu rosto e meu corpo a
sociedade mais uma vez me chegou como um
corpo estranho e não tava de acordo com
o que eles esperavam eu era um corpo
diferente mutação as pessoas olhavam
para mim me tratavam como atração de um
circo
quando elas Descobriram que na verdade
eu era um homem TRANS e não alma esses
elas me chamavam no canto e apresentava
para outras pessoas como não é verdade
que você é menina
E então eu comecei a me questionar
é mas como assim isso nunca nunca vai
acabar eu sempre vou estar no corpo
errado eu sempre vou ser o errado Quando
é que eu vou ter paz
comecei a ganhar uma passa habilidade
que assim eu estou assim dessa forma e
você não saberia dizer se eu sou uma
pessoa transe ou não
Oi e a partir disso eu comecei a me
introduzir no universo masculino
bom e foi aí que eu fiquei mais triste
ainda com essa situação de gêneros e
identidades e performance porque eu
entendi que mais uma vez eu tava ali
perto formando um gênero e não Era
exatamente que não era eu tinha feito a
transição para ser quem eu era Mas de
repente a sociedade também exigia que eu
fosse o que elas queriam que eu fosse
não que lá então a minha forma de sentar
tem que ser másculo o suficiente os meus
relacionamentos teriam que ser
heterossexuais eu não poderia mais
dançar em público como eu dançava antes
eu não poderia mais abraçar os meus
amigos homens em público como eu
abraçava antes a mesma sociedade que
antes me tratava com delicadeza que me
dava atenção me dava um abraço agora é a
mesma sociedade que me tratava com
agressividade
eu apertava minha mão bastante firme que
me cobrava uma postura viril
o e machista
e quando eu vi que isso tinha acontecido
eu me perguntei porquê
e Por que então eu tinha feito uma
transição se eu teria que ser mais uma
vez o que as pessoas queriam que eu
fosse não que eu queria ser para que eu
comecei a construir a minha própria
identidade enquanto o homem enquanto
homem transe enquanto pessoa trans
masculina por respeitando o meu corpo
respeitando os meus limites e
construindo que eu acreditava que era
melhor para mim e eu não precisava mais
ser agressivo ou machista para poder ser
homem agora Sinceramente
eu não queria mais saber que o mais com
essas me enxergavam eu só queria saber
como é que eu
e eu iria ser
a freak eu percebi
e
quem eu sou também
interferem como as pessoas são eu
percebi que a minha forma de encarar a
masculinidade poderia ser a forma de
outras pessoas também encararem a
masculinidade delas sem necessariamente
tem que modificar o corpo para isso
espero que eu comecei a aceitar o meu
corpo da forma que ele é
entender que não existe o corpo de homem
o corpo de mulher é o meu corpo
passei acertar o meu órgão sexual porque
ele funciona perfeitamente bem comecei a
aceitar Inclusive a possibilidade de ser
pai quer algo que eu sempre achei que
era impossível eu tinha esquecido que
meu corpo ele funciona tão bem que eu
posso gerar o meu filho em ser pai
Em uma sociedade onde Tamanho é
documento
nascer com a genitália que não é um
pênis é por si só uma negação do que é
ser homem para a sociedade então eu
jamais jamais
você considerado nessa sociedade de hoje
jamais você considerado um homem de
verdade
então eu parei de tentar mostrar para as
pessoas que sou um homem
se você fez muito agora vivo a minha
masculinidade e a minha pergunta é será
que é o meu corpo errado
se você é a sua mente sem preparo
E aí
quem
[Música]
será meu corpo é errado será a sua Nem
sempre é para o será teu corpo é errado
com a sua mente sem preparo
[Música]
sigo eu deste lado embaraçado tentando
enxergar pelo vídeo embaçado duas correm
do meu lado hein Por quais eu sou
considerado ficará linda nesse vestido
rodado na quadrilha não me deram uma
opção de se não e não não o Rei do
Cangaço
será a cor do errado será sua Nem sempre
é para o será meu corpo é errado com a
sua Nem sempre é pardo
[Música]
sou menino ou menina já não me tem
perguntado mas é só descobriu o meu
passado que de repente todo mundo
fica enganado
Dizem que sou respeitado o mar no
banheiro no mictório tá escrito
saia daqui mijado e eu que Deus e
adaptado será meu corpo errado será a
sua Nem sempre é para o será seu corpo é
e a sua mente sem preparo 1
[Música]
o ministério que eu nasci tocado por
alguma razão eu tenho que ser tratado
Mas eu sou a muito posso ganhar um pão
amassado estão enganados
eu nasci no corpo certo pelo contrário
já que para ser o meu tive que não
nasceu otário eu não quero ficar no
armário eu sou um boy cê tá e ficou
molhado quando eu estou excitado meu
corpo não tá errado
o meu corpo não sai errado
o meu corpo não tá
errado
o meu corpo não usa é errado
e a sua mente tem preparo E aí
[Música]
me respeite a nossa identidade de gênero
E aí
[Música]